welcome to this video plane Ceduna yeah
I recently had a game against him that I
remember so let's let's see if he
improves on the opening result because i
was completely winning but still managed
to lose I think that wasn't one of the
streams f5 I think this is how it is
play but I have to refresh my memory
there somewhat well sometimes it's the
right way to express it in the future I
even play a father anyway this is the
kind of player no matter if it works or
not no he doesn't that's surprising and
K should be true the sharp position Lex
King king is quite quite a weakened but
he still hopes to guess get some play
with those pawns there for you for
whatever never really understand why
this should be any good for black but it
will be yeah it's an old story with
those sub Kings India lines it's
objectively not very good but still
difficult to play so this is just one of
those positions I guess
King age seven looks very normal maybe
he's see afraid of something Bishop d3
or so on I can also just go F over here
this is a good strategic move I guess
let's do that yeah he wants to get the
night reform yep the LG g3 is hanging
home let's do it like that
position feels a bit shaky my position
here somehow with not having castled and
so on yeah here I don't know some way I
am attracted to playing at five yeah
keeping that Bishop out of the game
it looks okay I think he has to take it
185 otherwise if I get in g spot okay
this is also an interesting idea playing
44 now back here so I'm going to take
and cancel long that if all point is
weak but his um got this active Bishop
and should be four maybe just trade this
let's trade it I mean this King position
is not very good so looking on okie aid
yeah looky one is got rookie aid that
doesn't really lead to much
is threatening on g3 at least a little
bit very tough to play for 24 if it
takes now I've got Queen deform it seems
bit shaky for black oh that's a good
move if I guess if he gets Queens traded
that helps them and help some
hmm
check just going to try to trade one
look here I guess a black ass pad I've
speed played that well I guess
check probably just see two I cannot go
back with my king check
you two seemed simpler a lot simpler
check check check okay so see if I can
get both rooks check time morning ok now
we trade one check check check
that's a drone now I'm sure we've just
traded king of five as a self-made funny
you back check check draw offered game
draw all the luckiest Kim sham toughen
this is a well-known opening line h6 is
a move that I don't like it off a black
but ok so this point here hmm yeah maybe
f4 wasn't wasn't called for the engine
wants to do this and basically don't I'm
not killing says wide wins which I find
a bit high one point for which is almost
a win mm-hmm I have to be cautious with
the Commissaire Kings Indian positions
we know that already but let's say he
goes here what is the point then let the
engine wants to do this and says why
twins really winning 1.6 1.7 mm narrow
came it looks it looks pretty bad f4
Bishop d3 looks bad this is also not
looking very trustworthy they are maybe
okay a forward this is certainly ok now
for him that superb surprised me a lot
Knight takes looks far more natural okay
but he may be just castles eyelash I had
but seems that he got God enough play
this yeah he's got his head is getting
enough player black is definitely fine
him
and this is the Queen g5 was also a good
move check jam yeah I'm just clearly
worse check but I was surprised that he
went for this complicated stuff I
thought just eat two would be good
couldn't really figure out what I'm
doing then this is threatening okay to
maybe my acne worse in both cases Jeff I
guess check check a bit here yes it's
kind of at least somewhat playable
chakia no check he just has to trade and
this is Kitty is this bad i am voyance
to this is a channel because he cannot
escape checkmate funny self-made yeah
this was a lucky lucky draw thanks for
watching